الإجهاد موجود في كل مكان ، وعلى الرغم من أن
القليل من التوتر يمكن أن يساعدنا في الواقع على
تحفيزنا ، فإن الكثير من التوتر يمكن أن يؤدي إلى
مشاكل صحية خطيرة وفقًا
للأطباء ، يزيد الضغط من الكورتيزول
ومستويات الهرمونات الأخرى في أجسامنا والتي
يمكن أن تسبب تقدمنا في العمر وأن الشيخوخة يمكن أن تز
د من خطر الإصابة بالسرطان.  وي
التهابًا يمكن أن يؤدي إلى
فقدان الذاكرة من أمراض القلب والسكتة الدماغية ، لذا كيف
يمكنك تقليل التوتر
ينصح الأطباء بمحاولة التأمل
20 إلى 30 دقيقة على الأقل يوميًا ، أغمض عينيك
صمتًا عقلك والخروج من سباق الفئران
الحياة  حاول التنفس بعمق حقًا ،
فهو يساعد على تنظيم
الجهازين الرئوي والدورة الدموية
ويفتح الأوعية الدموية ، الأمر
الذي دفعك للالتقاء مع الأصدقاء للتحدث
عن مشاكلك ولا تحمل العبء
وحدك ومحاولة فهم أفضل
لإخوتك من البشر كن متعاطفًا
بدلاً من ذلك  من الغضب من الناس حاول
أن تضع نفسك في مكانهم ، فجميعنا نمر
بأيام سيئة في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم ،
أنا أبريل ويليا  آنسة